hey guys how do you lose weight
without exercise how do most models out
there
do it what is the secret to losing the
fat and looking
your best not exercising
that's what i'm gonna talk about in this
video so let's get to it
i um so i'll take it on i've made
mistakes but mistakes make you strong
now just very quick it's your first time
here on my channel i'm daniel and
welcome to dlm
model lifestyle on this channel i'll
talk about fitness grooming style
and life itself so if you haven't
subscribed yet please consider it and
then also click that notification bell
so you won't miss any of the next
videos now how do most models out there
lose weight fast without exercise
well there's a few ways but it's all got
to do
with nutrition the first way which is
something that i don't really want to
mention
is that models starve themselves not
really the experienced ones but the
beginner
ones you know especially girls when they
come into the modeling industry they
want to lose the weight
and then they just starve themselves
which is really bad because
they starve themselves until they cannot
hold it anymore and then they just
binge and they eat sweets and junk food
and a lot of
things are just unhealthy which is
terrible
and then when they're done they feel
terrible and they feel
guilty for just indulging and
angry at themselves and then they starve
themselves again and the whole
circle just continues again in this the
sick circle
i don't agree with it so don't do it and
then
some models try diets just like normal
people they try
diets as well some work some
do not really work that great but the
problem is go on a diet
until they can't really stick to it and
then they just
stop and then they gain all the weight
again then they go on another diet and
in this diet that diet
they try a lot of different diets and
it's the same thing they cannot stick to
it and then they just gain all the
weight
again so again we're at the circle which
is just keep repeating itself and it's
terrible
but then most models come to a point
where they realize
all right the best diet out there is
actually just the one that i can stick
to
because it's all about what's going on
in here
your mind and then it's not long before
most most models
realize okay it's not just about diets
it's about
maintaining a healthy lifestyle
most of the older professional models
know this
but still we do pick up some weight here
and there like
christmas time lockdown so what do we do
then
to lose weight even faster apart from
just going back to a healthy lifestyle
what do we do to
quickly lose the fat one of the things
most of us
do intermittent fasting it works and you
will
lose weight now i'm not gonna make this
video very complicated so i'm just gonna
explain it very basic so you can
understand
and follow me intermittent fasting works
this way you fast
a certain number of hours per day
and then the other you eat so for
example
one method is to eat eight hours and
then
the rest of the hours which is 16 comes
to 24
you fast now it sounds crazy but
remember
you sleep as well you sleep between
seven eight hours if
you maintain a healthy lifestyle right
now the 816 is just one method there's
actually
several methods but the 816 is one
that most people follow now let me give
you two easy ways that you can
do this you can eat from 9am to 5pm
and fast in the evening or you can eat
from 12
midday to 8 pm and nothing in the
morning
now you can bump it up to a 4 20 meaning
4 hours of the day you eat and then the
rest the 20
you fast now just remember the first day
will probably be
the hardest because your body is not
used to it so just remind yourself
when you fast yes i'm losing weight
while i fast yes yes yes keep yourself
motivated
and then the time when you do eat don't
just go crazy and eat unhealthy stuff
but eat healthy make your portion
smaller
if you're someone that's used to eating
a lot
like big portion sizes your stomach
you need to teach it to kind of shrink
and get used to
smaller portions so just get through
that first
day and then it will be a little bit
easier and remember
drink a lot of water you can drink water
the whole day
now studies on intermittent fasting
showed very powerful
effects for not only your body but also
for your mind
but okay apart from let's let's focus
here apart from
the mind let's look at your body how do
you lose
fat well again i'm not going to make
this video complicated so in short
when you fast your insulin goes down
other things also happen like your human
growth hormone
that goes up but the most important
thing is your insulin goes down when
your insulin goes down
that's when you lose fat because when
your insulin is high
your body stores more fat so
low insulin you lose fat and just to
recap here
intermittent fasting is good but
don't continue to eat and live the way
you used to there's
two important things you need to do that
i've already mentioned the first thing
is
don't just eat sweets sugar and a lot of
unhealthy stuff
instead eat healthy whole wheat grains
veggies
fruit and lean meats and number two eat
smaller
portion sizes for example if you want to
be 70 kilograms
don't eat like someone who is 90 kilos
you are what you eat you've heard that
quote before right
so you gotta eat according to what you
want to be
if you want to be 17 kilograms eat like
someone who is 70 kilograms
there are many tips and tricks that we
can talk about
but the most important thing is you need
to master your mind
before you can master your body
now the great thing about intermittent
fasting what i normally like to do is
you can merge intermittent fasting with
a good
diet like a low carb whole food diet or
the mediterranean diet or even with keto
but remember whatever you choose from
all the diets
the best diet out there in the world is
the diet that you can follow that you
can stick to
until you achieve the body you want
so merging intermittent fasting with a
good diet
will help you to lose fat fast without
exercise because
you always lose the fat in the kitchen
and you get fit in the gym but apart
from intermittent fasting and diets to
lose
fat fast the best thing that you can do
is to change to a healthy lifestyle
because that will keep the doctors away
and also the fat
now if you want more tips on a healthy
living and check out one of these videos
and i'll see you there cheers guys